Hi, my name is Pratip Banerji.
I'm a product manager on the
Google Play for Education team.
I'm excited to be
here today to talk
to you about Google
Play for Education.
What we've launched,
why we launched it,
and what we're launching
new this summer.
So just to start
off, when we built
Google Play for
Education, we went out
and we talked with
a bunch of educators
to really get a good
sense for the challenges
that they faced with deploying
technology in the classroom.
And what we heard from
them was four things.
First, we heard they really
wanted an affordable choice
of devices to use
in the classroom.
They wanted devices at
different price points,
with different sets of features,
with different form factors.
Second, we heard that
IT departments really
wanted a solution that scales.
They wanted a solution that made
it easy to provision tablets.
They wanted a
solution that made it
easy to manage those tablets
once they were provisioned.
They wanted all this
in an environment
that was safe and secure for
student use in the classroom.
Third, educators told
us that they really
wanted to get tools
that empower teachers.
Teachers are close to students.
They see where
they're struggling.
they're succeeding.
Teachers want to be able to
find the content that they need
and actually manage which
things go out to students.
And last, we heard
educators wanted
a broad set of digital content
available at their fingertips,
ranging from apps to books
to videos that they actually
controlled and were
able to push out
to students when they needed it.
So I'm going to walk
through each of these areas
and talk a bit about
what we've done
to solve some of these problems.
So with Google
Play for Education,
we've made available a broad
set of Android devices.
Today, we've actually got a
seven inch Nexus tablet that's
available for
schools, as well as
a Samsung Galaxy
Tab for education.
We've also announced
that we're rolling out
an ASUS Transformer, as
well as an HP Slate 8 Pro.
What this means is that
schools can actually
choose from many different
types of tablets.
And when they buy
one of these tablets,
they know it's going to
work within the classroom
environment, and
they know it's going
to work with Google
Play for Education.
Once you buy one
of these tablets,
how do you actually
get it working
in a classroom environment?
Many of you have set
up Android tablets,
and you know that
it's multi-step.
So you have to add a
Wi-Fi configuration.
You' actually have to set
up a username and password.
You have to go and
download device policy.
And then you have
to download apps
that you want to
use on your tablet.
This is fine if you're setting
up a couple of tablets.
But once you're an IT
administrator that's
trying to do this for 5,000
tablets across the district,
it actually gets
pretty cumbersome.
So we built is this device
activation and set up tool.
So an admin downloads this
tool onto their device.
And then all they need to do
is NFC bump every other tablet
with this admin tablet.
And those tablets
automatically start
setting up Wi-Fi, adding a
student profile with a username
and password, downloading
device policy,
and downloading
any apps that need
to be pre-installed
on that device.
So then that tablet can be
just handed to a student.
So what this means is instead of
taking days or weeks to set up
a district of tablets, you could
do that in a matter of hours.
So once one of these
tablets is set up,
how does an educator
actually find content for use
on that tablet?
So with Google
Play for Education,
what we built is a new set
of search filters and browse
filters that let
educators find apps that
align with specific subjects,
that align with specific grade
levels, that actually
can align with
specific common core
curriculum standards as well if
applicable.
And the way we do this is
that we allow developers
to opt into Google
Play for Education.
And then any app that's opted
in goes to a third party network
of teachers that review
the app, make sure
that the app works well in
a classroom environment,
and assign metadata
to that app that
allows for us to surface
that app in the right way.
So for example, if
a third grade math
teacher is looking for an app
that teaches their kids how
to do multiplication,
they just look for math,
they look for third
grade, and they
look for a common core
curriculum standard that's
going to align with
multiplication.
And they're going to see
every single app that
exists within the Play
for Education Store that
aligns with that.
So once they've found an app,
how does the teacher actually
get this app into the
hands of the student?
Obviously, a teacher can use the
standard distribution mechanism
of putting in a student's
username and send to a student.
But the cool thing
that we've done
is we've actually
made the ability
to do bulk distribution
by having a teacher set up
Google Groups for a
classroom, for a entire grade,
or for subsets of a class.
And then when a teacher
actually provisions
to one of these groups,
the app is pushed out
to every single student
that's in the group.
So a teacher could set up a
group for basic math student
and a group for
advanced math students,
find apps that make sense for
each of those sets of students,
and then provision those apps
directly to those students.
And those apps will just show
up on the student's devices.
So with the apps that
are getting pushed out,
we've also build a broad
set of management tools
that really works for schools.
We heard from schools
that they really
did not want to pay
with credit cards.
That just didn't work
with their buying process.
So we built the ability
to accept purchase orders.
So the way this
works is a school
sends Google a purchase order.
Google logs that purchase order.
And then schools can make
purchases against that purchase
order with a balance declining.
And then on a monthly
basis, we invoice a school
so that they see how
much they've spent,
what they've spent it on.
The cool thing about this is
that this happens completely
transparently to the developer.
The developer doesn't
have to know anything
about purchase orders.
They just know that they
sold a certain number of apps
and that they get a
check in the mail.
We've also built tools
that allow for teachers
to manage the apps are actually
present on the devices.
So if a student is
done with an app,
a teacher's able to use
Google Play for Education
to remotely uninstall that app,
either from a specific student
or from a set of students,
as well as reassign that app
to another student if one
student is done with it
and another student
needs to use it.
So no digital content
solution in the classroom
would be complete without books.
So we've actually launched
a flexible rental model
that has publishers, including
top textbook publishers, as
well as trade
fiction publishers.
We've also made available
YouTube education videos.
So YouTube has a
broad set of content
that's available that works
great in the classroom.
Using Google Play for Education,
educators could actually
find those YouTube Edu videos,
using the same search criteria
that we have for
apps and provision
those videos to
students as well.
So what are we launching new?
This summer, we're
excited to announce
that we're expanding
the availability of Play
for Education to
Chromebook schools.
So for those of you
that don't know,
Chromebooks are
doing extremely well
in the classroom environment.
In 2013 Q4, 25% of all edu
devices sold were Chromebooks.
And over 10,000 schools
are using Chromebooks today
by millions of students.
So this summer, admins
of Chromebook schools
are going to be able to enable
Google Play for Education
on their domains, which is
going to allow educators
in those domains to find
the same book and video
content that Android Edu schools
can find, as well as find
Chrome apps that are available
in the education space.
And all this content can
be provisioned and managed
using the same
management tools that
are available for
Android schools.
The last thing that we're
launching this summer
that we're super
excited to be announcing
is the ability for teachers to
leave tips for other teachers.
What we've heard over and
over again from teachers
is that they want to
know what's working
for other teachers
in the classroom.
So what we are enabling
now is allowing a teacher
to actually leave a tip that
talks about an app, what
the goals were when they used in
the classroom, how they used it
in the classroom.
They can link to YouTube videos
showing how they used it.
They can link to a curriculum
or a lesson plan that
shows how it really
worked in the classroom.
So then other teachers
that are actually
looking for content
in the classroom
can go read these
tips, can learn
how this app worked for other
teachers with similar profiles,
and can really
make the app shine
within their
classroom environment.
So what's next?
If you're an Android
developer that's interested
in participating in
Google Play for Education,
go to developer.android.com/edu.
There you can learn
more about what
it takes to build
an awesome K-12 app,
as well as understand what
the processes is to opt in
to have your app included
in Play for Education.
If you're a Chrome
app developer,
we're not quite ready
to accept your app
in Google Play
for Education yet.
We're launching with a
small set of developers
and a small set of apps.
But we're going to be
expanding and opening
Google Play for Education
up to you very soon.
Go to developer.google.com/edu
if you're interested
in learning more about what
it takes to build a cool app
for the classroom environment
and fill out the form that lets
us notify you when we have
the opt in process available.
If you're an interested
Chromebook school,
please go to
play.google.com/edu.
You can actually opt in to start
using Google Play for Education
right away.
If you're a school that's
interested in Android tablets,
check out google.com/edu/play,
and you can actually learn how
to set up Android tablets
within your classroom as well.
Thanks a lot and
happy schooling.